[Music]
climate change is the most epic threat
our species has ever faced it's a really
difficult thing to conceptualize because
even though climate change is touching
literally every square inch of this
planet it's hard to show people how it
might be affecting them personally but
what scientists are finding recently is
that maps can help communicate with
threat we spoke with one of those
scientists Matt Fitzpatrick who created
an interactive map to show what the
future climate of cities may be click on
San Francisco for example and you'll see
that in 2080
its climate will feel closest to
present-day Los Angeles Chicago will
feel more like eastern Kansas and
Washington DC will feel more like the
middle of Mississippi so the scientists
and a science communicator what is the
biggest challenge you're facing when
communicating climate change to the
public one it's it's a complex topic but
one of the biggest things is the amount
of misinformation out there right people
see and read and hear all sorts of
things that are presented as facts and
they're not and the science is often
attacked even though the science is very
robust all that collectively is is
trying not to speak in abstract terms
trying to speak about personal values
personal experiences personal stories
that people can relate to and I think
that's the angle that that this approach
climate analog mapping tries to take so
can you explain to us what this map is
and what it is showing so what the map
shows for 540 cities in North America is
the current location that is most like
that that city's future climates
speaking in terms of a particular city
is helpful so we can take New York City
and we can say what location now has a
climate like New York's is expected to
be in 2080 we can do that for two
different futures if you will one future
assuming we don't put policies in place
to change our behaviors and fossil fuel
use so that's kind of a high emission
scenario in the second scenario assumes
that we address the emissions problem
and reduce emissions to look at those
two possibilities and understand how
addressing
change can can help if you see any kind
of generalizable trends here yeah I mean
the strongest consistent patterns were
actually about the eastern half of North
America or so so cities in the East
their closest match in ms all cases was
to the south or Southwest if you're a
resident in a city in the East you would
have to drive about 500 miles to the
south to find a climate today like your
cities can experience in 2080 if we
think of Eastern cities we think for
seasons we think snowy winters a lot of
those cities are moving from those kinds
of climates to the more like what we
might consider subtropical humid
southeastern deep south us the West is a
little bit more complicated mainly
because of the terrain right there's
mountains and things like that the
weather patterns a little bit more
complicated and precipitation tends to
be a lot more seasonal in the West right
you get a lot of winter precipitation
and droughts in the summer but all
places in the West are warming up as
well a lot of the places in the West are
becoming more like Southern California
more desert I think another powerful
thing about this map is the implications
for things like public health so in a
place like San Francisco here we have
very few residences with
air-conditioning because it's just it's
a mild climate that will not be the case
in the future where we start looking
more and more like Los and just how
might a tool like this inform really
public health policy going forward into
a much warmer world I think there are
opportunities for people involved in in
that area and to look at these maps and
say if our city is going to become more
like a city in the south how are they
handling heat waves what do they have to
deal with higher temperatures how do
they protect their most vulnerable
population during those times I think
another big component of this is water
not just rising temperatures but the way
that rainfall will be changing so places
like Los Angeles is projected to have
fewer storms but those storms will be
more intense dumping more water at one
time in LA is actually preparing for
that with some catchment systems but we
talked about the importance here of
considering climate change both as a
temp
change but also a change in rainfall a
lot of similar work to ours that had
been done previously and still being
done it mainly focused on temperature
and we experienced temperature directly
right I mean of course we get rained on
but it's easier for us to experience a
heatwave than it is a 30% increase in
precipitation but precipitation is
really really important for the reasons
you mentioned right we of course rely on
fresh water and so places that have
built infrastructure and have planned
around a certain amount of precipitation
falling in a given year drastic and
changes in that it's going to affect a
lot of people so I think it's really
important to bring in the dimension of
of rainfall and to incorporate that into
the analysis can you talk about what
kind of ecological effects we might see
in the coming years as the planet
warrant your climate is a really
important determinant to what organisms
live where right so that means plants
insects animals what have you and when
we start changing the environment and
climate starts changing animals tend to
move around to an essence find their
preferred habitat you know some of these
organisms that are moving around our
disease vectors more mosquitoes certain
species of mosquitoes and certain
diseases that they carry are all going
to be affected and respond to climate
change and that's gonna directly affect
humans when when those are vectors of
disease and other things like that so
given the enormous scope of climate
change the dire nature of it for the
future of the human race what as
individuals might we be able to do in
eliciting change well a couple of things
I like to say we've we all contribute to
the problem so we can all contribute to
the solution if we look at what
contributes to emissions you
transportations a big one power
generation is a big one I live in
Maryland in Maryland we were able to
choose our power supplier and so we're
able to choose a supplier that purchases
renewable energy so if people live in a
state where they have that that ability
to pick where their power is coming from
they can switch today they can switch
from
so fuel source to renewable sources that
would have a major impact what's the
utility of a map like this and
communicating the the really dire
consequences of climate change the
climate change is hard for people to not
now understand per se but but maybe to
appreciate the the the risk because one
you know we experience a lot of
variability and climate daily weekly
seasonally right we might see a twenty
degree fahrenheit change from night time
to the maximum temperature of the day
but then we hear climate scientists
talking about climate change and being
worried about you know four degree
change in mean global temperature and
it's like well you know that doesn't
seem so bad and and so I think the
utility of this tool is to translate
those those abstract global averages
that we hear all the time into an actual
impact assessment of where people live
I think it's powerful for people to see
the the magnitude of change that we
expect just given relatively small
changes in mean global temperature okay
well thank you very much for joining us
my pleasure man